if you're on this general there's a
reason you're going there i mean maybe
someone set you up on that or maybe you
reached out to this person in some kind
of way
what are general meetings and what is
their purpose
a general meeting is a meeting that
usually maybe your manager or an agent
or you know maybe somebody that you know
uh will
you'll go on or set you up with and this
is usually with you know maybe a
producer at a company or a development
executive or
you know some person who is in a
position to
maybe green light a project
and you might just um get to know
somebody and have a conversation or they
might want to get to know your work
whether you're a writer or director
or whatever
and i guess the purpose of them is just
to put a face to the name and network
and see if you guys can find
a project that you're both interested in
or you know in most cases if they're you
know one of the kind of gatekeepers to a
place like a netflix or something yeah
they might have something that they're
looking for and and you can at least
have those conversations
do you still go on general meetings
from time to time yeah i think
early in my career
i would go on a lot of them
and i think you know they were good but
a lot of times it's it's you meet some
people you have some conversations and
they don't amount to anything
but you know years later you can
hopefully
blossom that into you know some kind of
opportunity or project later on
but now i think if i'm going on a
general meeting i try to be a little
more uh specific or or
understand like what the context of the
meeting is like if there is
something specific we want to talk about
or if there is
something that they're looking for i try
to be a little more prepared in that way
are you more likely to go on more of a
pitch meeting rather than a general
meeting um
well i guess i'll say you know it's
never a bad thing to to meet someone or
to go on a general
i just think
maybe framing a general meeting as
more of a pitch can be more productive
overall i mean it doesn't have to be
it's not that you always have to like
sell an idea or something but
if this person is taking time out of
their day and meeting you
under the context that you're a
filmmaker of some kind i mean they want
to know what films you want to make so
it's just something that you
you know should
have prepared for that more or you know
have um
just so that you don't waste their time
essentially
what advice would you give someone who's
going on their first general
um let's say they graduated from film
school
and and they're nervous they're excited
what would you tell them to how would
you
tell them to prepare
um i guess i would say
uh maybe do a breathing exercise before
you walk into the room if you're feeling
nervous
and then also too like i mean
i'm assuming that you know if you're on
this general there's a reason you're
going there i mean maybe someone set you
up on that or maybe you reached out to
this person in some kind of way
and my assumption would be that you sent
them a film that you made or maybe you
sent them
some kind of query letter that had your
your work in it um so maybe just just uh
brush up on
on what it is that you're going into the
meeting for and and
think about
ideas that you might have or may want to
talk about or think about the film that
you made that maybe they saw or the
script that you wrote that they read and
just just be ready to talk about that so
that way um
you're just
not as nervous and you're not as
that you are prepared to talk about the
project that you're working on
anything they should bring
i know you said don't worry about like a
powerpoint presentation maybe but i i
would i would say you know in a general
don't worry about bringing anything yeah
um
i think you can just go in and have a
conversation uh which is totally fine
and then later on if there's something
very specific like if they're calling
you in because they want to talk to you
about a very specific movie
um that they want you to pitch on then
then by all means you know bring in
whatever you feel like helps uh get your
vision across
what if they say it's a general
but for whatever reason the person
sitting behind the desk
thinks it's a pitch meeting and so then
you don't want to be the deer in
headlights and not have anything ready
what would you advise someone just just
on that off chance and it's like a
couple hours before what should they
have in their mind that if that person
asks them something they'll be ready
well people always say like you know
have your elevator elevator pitch uh
ready to go i mean it's kind of true i
mean
definitely
if you have ideas for movies you know
just have that log line in your mind or
have like the most concise succinct
version that you can pitch and even if
it's you know some people like have
ideas that are very complicated it's
like you want to get your idea in the
most digestible
version possible so have that prepared
and so that
when people ask you about those things
you can
just it's just muscle memory it just
comes out naturally so that's something
that you can definitely practice and you
can practice with your friends or
whatever so um definitely worth
having that skill set developed sure so
instead of charades practice your log
line yeah sure
that actually because that makes sense
because it is i'm sure nerve-wracking
and maybe most people in the log lines
i've given to different script people
they've said they're too long
or sometimes too it's like you know
sometimes even the log line isn't good
it's like there's there's something that
is more appealing about you know a a
movie idea or like you know what
whatever is the most like interesting
aspect to that to your idea i think is
what you want to pitch and that might
not be the log line that might actually
just be
a certain relationship in the movie
how much work do you line up for
yourself through general meetings
probably not a lot of work comes
just through a general meeting i mean i
feel like if it does come through a
general meeting it pays itself off like
six months later or a year later um
a lot of times the work comes from
you know uh
i don't know i can come from i guess it
can come from many places it can come
from
um just previous things that you've done
where people kind of just write cold
emails and they're just like hey like i
saw you did this thing or hey you wrote
this thing i'd love to talk to you about
this project um but there aren't
that many examples where
i went into a situation that was a
framed as a general meeting and then
right then and there they were like oh i
want to hire you for this i mean maybe
i've not been good in my meetings or
something but i feel like usually the
general meetings are just there to kind
of have a conversation and then later on
down the line
they might manifest into something more
work related
how do you navigate these meetings um i
think you just have to be a person and
feel it out at first right like you know
they're there to have you in there have
a conversation with you
um and
you just kind of have to let the
conversation go the way that it goes um
you know you don't want to come in guns
a blazing and say like all right here's
my five ideas and you know hijack the
the
the meeting um but yeah just just be in
there and just be present with the
person and then you know if the
conversation goes a certain way
then that's when you maybe pull out what
might be appropriate to to pitch an idea
for
you